um he's given up a pawn in order to get
the rooks off the board but yeah dead
draw the black bishop will protect his
pawn on the left side no way through for
either pawn there and on the other side
of the board the black king will act as
a blockader
easy draws the evangel mentions
white not having enough material to
convert now right you need past pawns on
both sides of the board you need to have
all sorts of things in order to win an
opposite color bishop in game and look
at it you need two extra pawns and for
them to be far apart here white only has
one extra pawn easy to blockade look at
the black king yeah you can never evict
it from that square no
and this is the sad thing about opposite
color bishops you're they're destined to
never meet
it's very kind of very dark as well
and there we go the players they
actually pre-move the last couple of
turns they repeat the position it's a
draw all right and
no smiles on either of those faces but
it is an okay start to the semi-finals
for both magnus carlsen and levon
aronian they are tied
after the first day of semifinals